hello everyone my name is Sarah and I am
part of the simply learn team welcome to
this session on idiom so now let's take
a look what's in it for all of us today
we will be talking about what is a
theorem the features of etherium like
cryptocurrency smart contracts aetherium
virtual machine decentralized
application and it uses and
decentralized autonomous organization we
also looking at applications of etherium
and a demo on part contract deployment
on a locally running it even client now
what is it theorem if helium is a
blockchain based computing platform that
enables developers to build and deploy
these centralized applications
so basically etherium is a platform
where we can build applications which
are not run by a centralized Authority
you can create a decentralized
application where the participants of
that particular application are the
decision-making authority so the hell we
can see etherium allows us to build and
deploy DAP applications so what are the
typical features of atheneum etherium
allows you to use its own cryptocurrency
called ëthe it allows development and
deployment of smart contracts it
provides you the underlying technology
the architecture the software which
understands smart contracts and allow
you to interact with it which is called
aetherium virtual machine then it allows
eventually to create consolidated
applications called decentralized
applications and also it allows you to
create decentralized autonomous
organization now let's talk about
aetherium cryptocurrency ether it is a
cryptocurrency that runs on aetherium
network basically it is the fuel which
is running the etherium network it is
used to pay for the computational
resources and the transaction fees for
any transaction to be executed on a
aetherium network like Bitcoin ether is
also a peer-to-peer currency
apart from paying for transaction ether
is also you used to buy gas which is
used to pay for computation of any
transaction you make on a aetherium
network also if you have to deploy a
contract on a theorem
you will need gas and you would have to
pay for that gas in ethers so gas is the
executive fee paid by a user for running
a transaction in ethelia ether can be
utilized for building decentralized
applications for building your smart
contracts and making standard
peer-to-peer payments now what is a
smart contract a smart contract is a
simple computer program that facilitates
the exchange of any valuable asset
between two parties it could be money it
could be shares it could be property but
it could be any other digital asset
which you want to exchange these
contracts can be created by anyone on
the etherium network and primarily the
contract consists of the terms and
conditions mutually agreed between the
parties between the peers and the
primary feature of a smart contract is
that once it is executed it cannot be
altered and any transaction done on top
of a smart contract is registered
permanently it is immutable so even in
future you modify the smart contract the
transactions correlated with the
original contract does not get altered
but you cannot modify them so for the
verification process smart contract is
carried out amongst the anonymous
parties of the network without the need
of a centralized Authority and that's
what makes any smart contract execution
on aetherium a decentralized execution
it provides the transfer of any asset or
currency in a transparent and a
trustworthy manner as the two entities
are totally unaware their identity is
secured on the etherium network though
the transactions one successfully done
the accounts of the sender and receiver
are updated accordingly and there's why
it dinner eights a trust between the
parties who are transacting using the
etherium network now what happens in
traditional system of contract in
traditional systems of contract you sign
an agreement then you trust a third
party hire a third party for execution
now the problem is that in such an
engagement the data tampering is
possible now if you talk about the new
smart contract the agreement is coded
in a program now result is not verified
by a centralized Authority it is
verified by the participants on
aetherium based blockchain network now
once a contract is executed the
transaction is registered and it cannot
be altered or tampered so it removes the
risk of any data manipulation or
alteration now let's take another
example where Zack has given a contract
of $500 to Elsa for developing his
company's website now the developers
code the agreement of smart contract
using a theorems programming language
now the smart contract has all the
conditions the requirements for building
the website once the code is written it
is uploaded and deployed on the etherium
EVM virtual machine EVM is a runtime
compiler to execute your smart contract
once the code is deployed on the EVM
every participant on the network has a
copy of the contract now now when Elsa
submits the work on etherium for
evaluation each node on the etherium
network will evaluate and confirm
whether the result given by Elsa is done
as per the coding requirements and once
approved and verified the contract worth
$500 will be self executed and the
payment will be paid to Elsa in ethers
so drawn account the person who had gone
into a contract his account will be
automatically debited and Elsa will be
credited with $500 in ether denomination
here we will now take a look we will do
a demo small demo on a deployment of a
smart contract so for in order to
execute our smart contract we will need
to set of softwares
Ganesh and truffle and we will show you
in the demo how to install these two
software's on your machine now we will
be giving a demo on the following smart
contract this is a smart contract where
we are writing a simple contract of
greeter we have a variable called
greeting which we will be initializing
using a constructor and then in our demo
we will be showing how you can change
the value of the variable greeting using
the set greeting method and read the
value using the grid method this is the
other contract where we will be defining
that whoever is deploying the contract
on the blockchain network is always the
owner of the contract and then we have
defined certain mandatory functions in
order to kill the contract on the
etherium network so only the owner of
the contract can kill it now let's talk
about what is an ethereal virtual
machine each few muscle machine is
designed to operate as a runtime
environment for compiling and deploying
aetherium base smart contracts basically
EVM is the engine which understands the
language of smart contracts which are
written in solidity language for
ethereal EVM is operated in a sandbox
environment basically you can deploy
your own standalone environment which
can act as a testing and a development
environment and you can n number of
times test your smart contract deploy it
verify it and then once you are
satisfied with the performance and the
functionality of the smart contract you
can deploy it on the etherium main it
now
any programming language in the smart
contract is compiled into the bytecode
which the EVM understands this bytecode
can be read and executed using an
etherium feature called aetherium
virtual machine so basically EVM machine
understands a bytecode so one of the
most popular languages for writing a
smart contract is solidity so once you
write your smart contract on solidity
that contract gets converted into the
bytecode and gets deployed on the ebee
and thereby a VM guarantees security
from cyberattacks now how does EVM work
so suppose a wants to pay B 10 ethers
the transaction will be sent to the EVM
using a smart contract for a funds
transfer from A to B now in order to
validate the transaction the etherium
network will perform the proof-of-work
consensus algorithm the minor nodes on
the etherium will validate this
transaction whether the first the
identity of a exists or not a has the
relevant amount of balance to transfer
10 ether to B and in will validate the
transaction once validated the ether
will be debited from a wallet and will
be credited to Bea's wallet and during
this course the miners
we'll charge a fees in order to validate
this transaction and we'll earn a reward
now all the nodes on aetherium Network
execute smart contract using their
respective events now how does roof up
work works every node in the etherium
network has the entire history of all
the transactions the entire chain it has
the history of smart contract which
basically the address at which the smart
contract is deployed the transactions
associated with the smart contract and
also it has the handle to the current
state of the smart contract now the goal
of the miners on the etherium lock check
network is to validate the block for
each block of transaction miners use the
computational power and resources to get
the appropriate hash value by varying
the nonce now the miners will vary the
nonce and pass it through a hashing
algorithm in case of a theorem it is the
it hash algorithm this produces a hash
value which should be lesser than the
predefined target as per the proof of
work consensus if the hash value
generated is less than the target value
then only the block is considered to be
verified and the miner gets rewarded
only then now when the proof of work is
solved result is broadcasted and shared
with all the other nodes in order to
update their ledger if other nodes
accept the hash block as valid then the
block gets added to the etherium memnet
blockchain and as a result the miner
receives a reward which as of today
stands at 3 ethers plus the miner
receives the transaction fees which has
been generated for verifying the block
all the transactions which are
aggregated in the block the cumulative
transaction fees associated with all the
transaction is also rewarded to the
miner now do you know in atheneum a
process called proof of stake is also
under development and it is an
alternative to proof of work it is meant
to be a solution to minimize the use of
expensive resources you spent for mining
using proof of work now in proof of
stake the miner is actually the
validator can validate the transactions
based on the amount of crypto coins
your she holds before he or she can
start the mining so based on the
accumulation or the repository of crypto
coins with the miner beforehand we'll
give him the fire probability of mining
the block the however proof of stake is
not widely adopted as of now as compared
to proof of four Kelvin
now let's understand the concept of gas
now it's in virtual machine has a
concept of gas and why do we need it so
like we need fuel to run car in the same
way in order to run application on
aetherium Network we need gas now what
is gas to perform any transaction with
helium network a user has to make a
payment has to shell out ethers in order
to get the execution done the
transaction done and the intermediary
monetary value is called as guests on
etherium network gas is a unit that
measures the computational power
required to run a smart contract or a
transaction so if you have to do a
transaction which is updating the
blockchain you would have to shell out
gas and that gas will come with a price
in ethers now how is the gas feasts
calculated in aetherium the transaction
fees is calculated in aetherium using
the below formula for every transaction
there is a gas and the correlated gas
price so the amount of gas required to
execute a transaction multiplied by the
gas price you generate their transaction
fees so gas limit on it 3m network
refers to the amount of gas which is
used for the computation and the amount
of ether a user is required to pay for
the gas now here we have a screenshot
from the ATM nail minute where the cost
of transaction is being shown so if you
see for this particular example
transaction the gas limit was 21
thousand the gas used by the transaction
was 21 thousand and the gas price was 21
gooey which is the lowest denomination
so 21 3 into 21,000 gave you the actual
transaction fees which is 0.2 / 0 for 4
1 ether which is approximately 0.2 one
cents as of today is ether market value
now this transaction fee goes to the
miner who has validated the transaction
to understand the
as limit and the gas price in a better
way let's consider an example of a car
suppose your car has a mileage of 10
kilometers and the price of petrol is $1
per litre then driving a car for 50
kilometres will cost you five liters a
patrol which will be worth five dollars
similarly to perform an operation or to
run a code on aetherium you need to
obtain certain amount of gas like the
patrol where each gas has a per unit
price called gas price now if the user
provides less amount of gas to run a
particular operation then the process
will fail and the user will be given a
message or out of gas and buoy is the
lowest denomination of ether which is
used for measuring unit of a gas price
now how is it helium's mining different
from Bitcoin mining the hashing
algorithm is the primary difference the
Bitcoin uses sha-256 helium uses it hash
the average time taken on Bitcoin for
mining a block is 10 minutes whereas any
theorem it is 12 to 15 seconds as of
today the mining reward for Bitcoin is
0.5 BTC but for a theorem is if 3 eaters
plus the transaction fee the cumulative
transaction P for all the transactions
for a block now as of 23rd July the
Bitcoin value was seven thousand six
hundred and sixty-seven dollars whereas
one either times at four hundred and
sixty six dollars now here we have a
screenshot of aetherium reward which has
been given to the miner of the block now
as you can see here is the break up of
the reward three ethers plus the total
accumulated transaction fee of all the
underlying transactions in this block
which is point zero six six six ethers
now what is a decentralized application
now let's compare it with our
traditional applications our traditional
websites which are currently running so
for example when you log in to tutor a
web application gets displayed which is
rendered using an HTML page now the page
will call an API to access your personal
data your information which is centrally
hosted now it's a simple process your
front-end executes the backend API and
the API goes and fetches the information
from a centralized DB now if it's
from this application into a
decentralized application then now when
you will log in the same ever
application will get rendered but it
will be calling a smart contract based
API to fetch the information from the
blockchain network so the API gets
replaced with the smart contract
interface and the smart contract will
fetch the information from the
blockchain Network which is its back end
and that blockchain network is not a
centralized DB it's a decentralized
network where the participants of the
network the miners of the network are
validating verifying all the
transactions which are happening using
the smart contract on the blockchain
network so thereby any now any
transaction or any action happening on
the Twitter kind of application which
has been transformed will now cannot be
claimed as a centralized transaction it
will be a decentralized transaction
adapt a decentralized application
consists of backing code that runs on a
distributed peer-to-peer network it is a
software designed to work on in
aetherium network without being
controlled by a centralized system and
that is the primary difference it
provides the direct interaction between
the end users and the decentralized
application providers now an application
qualifies as that when it is open
sourced its code is there on github and
it uses a public blockchain base token
in order to run the application a token
acts as a fuel for the decentralized
application to run dap allows the
backend code and data to be
decentralized and that is the primary
architecture of any DAP now let's
discuss what are decentralized
autonomous organizations
Dow's is a digital organizations that
wants to operate without any need of a
hierarchical management it wants to
operate in a decentralized and a
democratic fashion so basically a Dao is
an organisation where the
decision-making should not be in the
hands of a centralized Authority but it
should be in the hands of certain
designated authorities or a group or
designated people as a part of authority
it exists on a blockchain network where
it is governed by the
coal's embedded in a smart contract and
thereby they rely on a smart contract
for decision-making all the business
decisions are driven by the smart
contracts or we can say a decentralized
voting system within the organization so
any the organizational decision before
being taken has to go through the voting
system which is running on a
decentralized application so hard work
people add funds through the doubt
because thou requires funding in order
to execute and take decisions based on
that each member is given a token on a
percentage basis which represents the
percentage of shares of that particular
member in the DAO now those tokens are
used to vote in the DAO where the
proposal status is decided based on the
maximum words so every decision within
the organization has to go through this
voting process now let's take a look
what are the applications of etherium in
real world and where it is getting used
so as we have seen with dau voting
system are adopting it the results of
the polls are publicly available where
it ensures a transparent and fair
democracy by eliminating voting mal
practices it is getting adopted widely
in a banking scenarios and banking
systems with Athenians decentralized
system it is becoming very difficult for
hackers to have unauthorized access and
it also allows payments on a aetherium
base network so banks are also using
aetherium as a channel to make
remittances and payments shipping
deploying aetherium in shipping helps
tracking of cargo and prevents goods
from being misplace or counterfeited so
basically the theorem is providing you
of the provenance and tracking framework
for any kind of asset required in a
typical supply chain
now with aetherium smart contract
agreements can be maintained and
executed without any alteration so any
industry which has fragmented
participants is subject to disputes and
which requires and digital contracts to
be present then aetherium can definitely
be used as a technology for developing
your smart contract and digitally
recording the agreements and the
transactions based on those
so let's get started for a demo on how
to deploy an ethereal smart contract
locally so in order to deploy a smart
contract we will be first installing
ganach client which allows you to host a
local aetherium client on which you can
deploy your smart contract so as we are
working on the Windows environment when
we are downloading the ganache setup we
can also download node order to install
a file on our machines
now as the node has been downloaded we
will install node
you
for now node is successfully installed
now we are going to install ganache
locally
now we will run ganache a little later
before that we will perform certain
steps or we can run ganache and see so
once ganache is up and running I will
show you the interface how it looks
so when Ganesh is brought up it
automatically creates 10 accounts with
pre-funded balance of 100 ethers it is
running on localhost port number seven
five four five now as you see there is
no transaction or anything which has
currently happened so the current block
is zero which is the genesis block there
are no transactions and there are no
blocks as of now so there are no
transactions in block which have been
generated so using this ganache klein
now we will be deploying our greeter
contract now as we have installed node
he will be a link truffle shuffle is the
utility which allows us to compile and
deploy aetherium contracts okay now once
a truffle is installed we need to create
a directory called greeter
now we need to run the command truffle
now once we run this command a full by
default P it's a packet structure which
has three folders called contracts
migrations tests truffle dot J's and
truffle config now we will be writing
our smart contract called greeted or
soul and we will compile and deploy
basically our glitter dot soul will be
under contracts folder and we can
our contract is created and it is lying
under contracts folder now we need to
add another file under migrations folder
called as deploy contract or G's
so we will emit as deploy contract
now in this deploy contract you need to
put enough code
now in this file we are asking truffled
to deploy our newly created greeter dot
sol file now in the greeter contract we
have a constructor we are initializing
the greeter contract with a value hi
hello and we are passing a gas value so
this gas is currently at a higher limits
and we know that this gas value the
contract will get executed but otherwise
you can also evaluate the gas value of a
contract using remix now once this file
is being saved you go to the truffle dot
J's and Inc the following entry
oh here we are trailing truffle that our
localhost ganache client is running on
localhost at port number seven five four
five and network ID can be anything
though the current ganache client is
running on port network ID five triple
seven but we have kept it open that we
can connect to any network ID now after
this step to go back to my command
prompt and say truffle combined
now if you get this error if we are
getting this kind of error in Windows
then need to do one quick fix
you need to go to the users directory
and rename truffle dot CMD to trough so
I'll go to my drive users abdi coming
him just
oh here now instead of truffle
said ruff
oh there might be certain compilation
warnings we can ignore that now my
contract is being compiled now I need to
run the next command trough my great
at this stage my smart contract is
deployed and now you can see
this is the step this is the place where
the contract has been called and this is
the transaction where the default value
of my variable greeter has been said to
hi hello so we will see now I need to
run command trust console to interact
with my contract
now as on my truff console I can check
at what address is my contract deployed
so my contract is deployed at address 0
x3 7 which matches with the address 0 x3
7 tree
how I need to check the default value
which I had said while deploying my
contract so this is my value hi hello
now I can change the value to something
else because in my greeter contract I
have a method called set greeting now
whenever when I will be performing this
action a new block will get generated
and the block count will increase from
four to five because I am making a
change on the blockchain as you can see
now a new transaction has been created
this was the gas used this is the
default gas price in ganache and block
number five is been mine now I can
reread the value of the variable now it
will return me latest value which is
change grid value so this demonstrates
how to use a solidity contract how to
compile it deploy it on a locally
running blockchain network you can
connect multiple nodes to this ganache
client and all the nodes should be
running on the same network ID should
have the same network ID but they can be
running on a different machine so here
we can see all the other details the
block the transactions which have
happened if I perform the action again
number six has been generated has
another transaction associated with it
and I can get the latest value so what
are the key takeaways for today we
understood about aetherium the features
of aetherium different applications of
aetherium and what is a smart contract I
hope you had a great learning session
and I'll meet you in the next session
thank you
hi there if you like this video
subscribe to the simple learn YouTube
channel and click here to watch similar
videos de nerd up and get certified
click here